- He cut the legs off the
jockstrap, so he would just—
- Wait, you wore a jockstrap?
- The best "Box 'Em Up" story
happened to Brian Urlacher.
- Ohhh my God.
♪♪♪
- ♪ Never mind,
I'll find someone like Hue ♪
♪ We wish nothing
but the best ♪
♪ for you ♪
- [Fake sobbing]
How did this happen?
- I mean, what?!
"How did it happen?"
Are you kidding me?
He's 3-36-1.
- I love it.
- That's how it happened.
- I need
to remind people
Bill Belichick would need
to lose 1,070 games in a row
to have a worse winning
percentage than Hue Jackson.
- That's a great stat.
Good job on that one.
- That's insane.
- Yeah, I like that.
- I mean, it's from Reddit.
- It's insane.
- Yes.
- But it's still insane.
- Welcome to "Simms & Lefkoe."
That was the news
of the weekend
but there's a lotta stuff
goin' on this week
and it is time
for midseason awards.
For our midseason awards,
we're not doing
[Robotic voice] MVP—
- At the halfway point
- Offensive Player of the Year, meh.
No, we have our own style
and first, we're doin'
Best Player No One's Talking
About in the First Half.
Who you going with?
- I'm gonna go with Cam Newton.
I mean, he's the quarterback
of a 5-2 football team.
- True.
- OK?
He does not get the respect
he deserves
because he doesn't throw
for 400 yards
and five touchdowns every week,
but I will say this
Trying to defend him can't be
quantified sometimes, Lefkoe.
- Oh my gosh.
- You know you like that word.
- That is the Worst Phrase
of the First Half of the Season.
I am gonna go deeper cut.
- Yes.
- I'm going Frank Clark
of the Seattle Seahawks.
- OK.
One of the league leaders
in sacks
and every time
I watch the Seahawks game
the quarterback is running
for his life from Frank Clark.
- Yep.
I mean, Cam's—I mean,
nobody gives Cam respect.
- All right, next up,
Good, Bad, Good Award
People that were good,
then they were bad,
then they were good.
I believe this should be called
the Ryan Fitzpatrick Award.
- Right.
- I am giving it
to Ryan Fitzpatrick.
- OK.
- It is synonymous with
not just his career
but also this season.
- Yes it is.
- He was incredible,
and then he disappeared
and then he's back again,
and it's amazing.
Who you goin' with?
- I'm gonna go with Dee Ford
on the Kansas City Chiefs.
- Ooh, deep cut.
- He was a first-round
pick, OK.
Kinda had a decent start
to his career
then everybody's like,
"Who is this guy?
He's horrible!"
He became an Internet meme.
- Yes.
- And now he's the best player
on the Kansas City defense.
- I like that one.
- All right, so everyone's gonna
focus on Coach of the Year.
We know that the real money
is made with coordinators.
- Right.
- Which coordinator do you wanna
give shine as Best
Coordinator in the First Half?
- Greg Manusky,
defensive coordinator
for the Washington Redskins.
No. 4 defense in football.
And all anybody remembers
about the year
is the Monday night game against
Drew Brees after a bye week.
Yeah, they laid
an egg that week
but other than that,
they've been phenomenal
and there's not a lotta
superstars on that defense.
- And they're No. 2
against rushing—
- There you go.
- Which is pretty amazing.
- Right.
- I have to give an apology
and an award.
Norv Turner, I am sorry
I made fun of you
this offseason
and said you had hired
your entire family tree
for your coaching staff
and that you quit on Mike Zimmer
in Minnesota.
And you've proven me wrong, sir.
- Way to self-scout yourself.
- 5-2, Carolina Panthers.
Cam Newton, this offense:
little bit of this,
little bit of that.
- Yep.
- Little bit of apology.
I'm sorry, Norv. You're the man.
Now the most important award
for our midseason extravaganza!
The Best Player that
People Think Simms Hates.
- Oh, OK. Jared Goff.
That would be the guy
that I think has had——
- People definitely think
you hate Jared.
- Yeah, they really do,
and I'll say, you know
I definitely was skeptical
about him coming into the year
but again, it's the plays
he makes that aren't there
that I think are
extremely impressive.
Scrambling,
people around the pocket
big throws down the field.
- Yes.
- He deserves credit.
- I think the player
that people think you hate
that's playing the best is Matt Ryan.
- He's been ballin'.
- And I would say it's been a
year-and-a-half of Matt Ryan
playin' the best football
of his career.
- Right.
- And it's—the team carried him
early in his career.
He's carrying the team
right now.
- Agree with that.
- And you don't hate Matt Ryan.
- I don't hate Matt Ryan at all.
- Good.
You know who else you don't hate?
- What?
- Brian Urlacher.
- Ooh, I like Urlacher.
- But you know
what Brian Urlacher hated?
- What?
- Being put into a box.
- Put into a box? Well, who
would like to be in a box?
- Apparently, the Chicago Bears.
- The best Box 'Em Up story
happened to Brian Urlacher.
- I can't believe you got him.
- The best. The greatest one.
We created this game
that was called Box 'Em Up
because everybody got,
like, Nike and Reebok shoes
and different things
and clothes
and then you'd have the boxes,
the cardboard boxes left over.
So people would be walkin', and
if they're not payin' attention
you just run up behind 'em
and slam a box over their head
and say, "Box 'em up!"
So everybody had to have
their head on a swivel
in the locker room.
So Brian was really good
at getting other people, too,
cuz he's sneaky.
Like, he'd get you comin' out of
your meeting room or something
and, boom, you got a box
slammed over your head.
He would get so many people
that, yeah
everybody kinda
had it out for him.
- Everybody turned on him.
He was the box bully.
- Yeah. It only took me once.
You get boxed on once—
- You got the head
on a swivel.
- Like, literally,
around the locker room
you got your back to the wall.
- [Laughing]
- I'm keepin' everybody
in front of me.
I think the D-line
brainstormed on, like
"What would be the best way
to try to get him?"
And, I mean, it was brilliant.
- I'm imaging the D-line
doing, like, a space shuttle launch.
- Yeah, they probably had,
like protractors and
all kind of stuff.
You know, it's Urlacher,
so you gotta get him.
- Yes, right.
- I don't know
how they got this box, but
it was like a six-foot box.
And in our locker room, there's
stairs to go to the second floor
where all the cardio stuff is
and there's a platform,
so you can't see who's up there.
So he comes out, and so right when
he walks out from
under the platform
somebody drops that six-foot box
right on his head.
He had his arms down.
It dropped, like,
straight over him.
He's like, "Ahhh! Ahhh!
I'm stuck in the box!"
And he's, like, trying
to get it off of him.
Everybody's like,
"Box 'em up!"
All you saw was
two little feet, like
kickin' out of the box
and stuff.
- [Laughing]
- That's awesome.
This is a special moment for me.
This is somebody that I love—
- Oh my gosh.
- With all of my heart,
Brian Westbrook!
- Dude, don't give him
your cellphone number.
- [Laughing]
- I'll text you all the time.
- Stage 9 clinger over here.
Don't do it.
- Love it, love it.
- All right, chill.
- Stalker alert!
- We just heard Matt Forte talk about pranks.
Eagles locker room:
you, Trot, T.O., McNabb
Freddie Mitchell,
all those guys.
Any pranks come to mind
right away?
- You named him—
Freddie Mitchell, always.
I'm not sure
that he ever practiced
or did anything with meetings,
but he loved pranks.
And this is a small one.
So, you go and you put your
jockstrap on, ready to play.
- Yeah.
- He'd cut the legs
off the jockstrap,
so you just—
- Just have that part.
- Just hanging.
But that wasn't the worst one.
- Wait, you wore a jockstrap?
I just wore spandex.
- Really?
- He believes no NFL players
wear cups.
- Well, not a cup—
- He knows they don't wear cups.
- But the jockstrap.
- I didn't know.
- I needed to be held in there,
secure. Yeah, of course.
- All right.
Just wanted to clear that up, OK.
- We're all secure here
in our manhood. Trust me.
[Laughing]
The other thing is, he was on
the Bucs, his spleen explodes—
Sorry for bringing it up.
- Yeah, it's all right.
- And, like, a few games later,
you guys go down to Tampa Bay
and you had one of
the greatest plays
I've ever seen
that no one will remember.
- We were up by about 20 points.
- You were up big, yeah.
- Furious comeback
and that was my first experience
seein' this guy right here.
- Little dump-off, like 50,
60 yards. You weaved in and out.
Break a couple ankles,
make some guys miss.
I'm kinda struttin'
to the end zone.
It's only a minute left.
There's no way, no way,
Tampa Bay's gonna
kick the return and return it.
- Right.
- Bruce Gradkowski.
- The starting quarterback's
not in there.
Simms is in there,
so there's no way.
- Exactly, exactly.
- And then Matt Bryant
kicked that 62-yard field goal
for the Bucs.
So you were filled with joy.
He was filled with pain.
- I was first filled
with amazement.
It was my first time that
I was on a field with him
and got to see him pull
some of these plays off
that he did
in the fourth quarter.
- Yeah.
- And he's ahead of his time
at that position.
- I agree.
- You know, now I feel like
there's a lot of guys—
- Lot of 'em.
- Like you around the NFL,
and that's the first place—
Like, who's the guy
you look at in the NFL
right now that you're amazed by
or reminds you of you
at running back?
- It's a couple guys.
I mean, Jerick McKinnon—
they were gonna use him—
- Yes.
- The same way that they used me.
Obviously, he gets injured.
Tarik Cohen, this last month of the season—
- That's the mensch! That's our guy.
- They continue to use him
more and more.
James White, Dion Lewis,
same type of guy.
- Something happened on Sunday.
I thought of you immediately.
- What’s that?
- Todd Gurley takes the ball,
runs down, slides right there
on the 1-yard line, no touchdown.
Fantasy players are going nuts,
Vegas is going crazy.
You did that to Dallas.
You know, I– of course I admire what
Todd Gurley continues to do week in
and week out, and having done
that against the Cowboys years ago,
I wish he would have scored.
I’m all about fantasy now.
When I was playing,
it wasn’t about fantasy, nothing.
Now I’m all like, listen, score as much
as you can, as often as you can.
I need it for my team.
- That’s nonsense. I was up against Gurley
and I was like, “you sit down and don’t
get in that end zone!”
- Exactly. You loved it, right.
- Pose the point that if they score the
touchdown and maybe miss the
extra point, which we see all the time–
-Yeah.
- It’s gonna be an 8-point lead and you’re still
gonna give Aaron Rodgers the ball back.
- That’s true.
- So did you wanna play with that kind of fire?
I wouldn’t have.
- In hindsight, now retired, and not having
to worry about the team winning–
- Cuz you got so much praise for it back then.
I know, people love it. Especially
people in Philly, they loved the play.
Everywhere else, they’re like,
“what are you doing?”
- I was gonna go to Andy Reid.
- That's exactly
where I wanna go too.
Just what he's doin' there.
- He's got a one-loss team
with Patrick Mahomes.
Do you have joy
watching this happen?
- I have so much joy.
I mean, I love Andy
as a coach, as a man.
Certainly a guy that
I looked up to
and appreciate everything
he did for my career.
Quick story:
When we got Mike Vick
I talked to Andy,
and he was like
"I've been drawing up plays
on napkins for Vick
just to get him in the game,
get him the football."
That's what
he's constantly doing
thinkin' of different plays.
And I can't imagine
what he's thinkin' about now.
- Yeah, right, that's where I wanna go.
- Hill, Kelce, Watkins, Hunt.
I mean, and he has a quarterback
now that wants to let it go.
So, I mean, to me,
that's like a joystick
"Madden" game type of offense
out there.
- What is it that the players
love about Andy Reid?
- Some coaches say
"Hey, Westbrook
just didn't do his job today"
and "He should've did this
and did that"
to kinda make up for
and show the media
and the fans who was wrong.
- Suddenly throw somebody under the bus.
- Yeah! "I wanna show you
what's the deal,"
and Andy was never like that.
He would always say, and the
media in Philadelphia hated it–
but when you're a player,
you love it.
Because that means
your coach has your back.
Now, he still told you
about yourself.
He still pointed you out on film
within the building
but he kept everything
inside of the building.
Andy was great with that.
- Westbrook, you're the man.
- Thank you.
- Hi, I'm Darron Lee.
- Whassup?
I'm Avery Williamson.
- And you're watching
the "Simms & Lefkoe Show."
- Pow.
- It's Niners, it's Raiders.
It's HomerCast
on "Thursday Night Football"
in the house
that Jim Tomsula built.
I'm Adam Lefkoe,
Raiders reporter
and let's bring in
the likely vegan
that often smells
like beans, Chris Simms.
Hey, there, Chris.
- Well, that was a nice shot
you took at our
brand new stadium
but at least we can afford one.
Black Hole?
More like Crap Hole.
- Just because we have
a baseball diamond
and we have multiple interests
doesn't mean we should be punished.
And by the way, we found
a beautiful new place
to settle down some roots.
- Oh, that's right.
Leavin' town once again, because
we know who runs this area.
It's the 49ers and our five
Super Bowl trophies.
Montana, Rice—eat that, Oakland.
- How many of those players does
Kyle Shanahan have on his team?
And by the way, how is
old Kyle doin' this year?
1-7. That's gotta hurt
that tattoo there, hey, partner?
- Oh, well, now, you
should talk. You're 1-6.
And at least our head coach
can afford a cool haircut.
And your owner,
he's got a little issue
in that department as well.
- If we're gonna talk
about appearances
it's kind of interesting
that your current quarterback
C.J. Beathard, looks like
a bagger at Trader Joe's.
He plays like one, too,
sometimes, Chris.
- Well, I can't deny that,
but we're lookin' forward
to 2019 when Jimmy Garoppolo
gets healthy.
- Meanwhile, we have three
first-round picks
and the future's bright, Simms.
- Oh, bright like
the Las Vegas Strip
next to Britney Spears.
That's great.
You're so good with first-round
picks, Lefkoe.
- Thanks, man.
- Yeah, you really are.
I mean, Darrius Heyward-Bey.
JaMarcus Russell.
Uh, Robert Gallery!
- I told you, please
don't mention JaMarcus.
- You guys stink.
- It's a sore—you stink too.
- I know.
- I don't even know why people
are watching this.
- Let's go watch "Young Sheldon."
- Thus far on
"Somebody & Lefkoe"
we've had four people.
We're up a little bit more
than $400
and it's time for our
ninth pick of the season.
"Somebody & Lefkoe"
is a success.
This time, New York City
won't let Grace make a pick.
Watch.
So my name is Adam,
and this is Grace
and she's a singer-songwriter,
and we've tried to do this
like 12 times
in front of this coffee shop.
But we've had cursing people,
a woman walk through.
It's been wild. Here's the deal.
Not the biggest NFL fan.
You've been to
a few Titans games.
- Yeah.
- How'd they do?
- They lost. I've never
been to a Titans
game where they won.
- Thursday night, it is
the Niners versus the Raiders.
The Niners have to win by 3.5.
What do you know about
both of these teams?
- I don't know much
about either team
but I do know the Raiders
are black and silver.
- Yes.
- They're in Oakland.
- Yeah. This feels like a strong team.
- So, do you feel more
comfortable cuz you know them?
- Yeah. Yeah, I'm
familiar with that team.
- Are you willing right now to
guarantee Raiders over Niners?
- Yes.
- It's official.
- Yeah.
- If you win, I'm back
with the money next week.
- OK.
Ma'am, please come on by.
Join "Somebody & Lefkoe."
Come on, come on in.
Yes. That's "Somebody & Lefkoe."
This is Grace.
She's pickin' the Raiders.
Yeah. Have a great day.
New York City.
- [Laughing]
All right, here's the deal.
We're doin' a prank.
Just Lefkoe and you guys.
So, it is the trade deadline.
We're recording this on Tuesday
and we thought
we'd fire up Photoshop
and convince Simms that Odell
is being traded to the Texans.
I think it's gonna work.
Even better, we're in full
costume because it's Halloween.
Look at this. [Laughing]
- Wow. That is amazing.
- Dangerous.
- How do you feel as a brunette?
- Negative, Ghost Rider.
The pattern is full.
- Ohhh my God. Oh my God.
- What?
- I think you're lying.
No?
- Oh my God.
- Did we say that
yesterday, right?
OBJ was traded to the Texans.
- Oh my gosh.
Are you guys seeing this?
- Bro. Bro.
- Yooo! ProFootballTalk!
Odell!
- Oh, poor Gabe.
Gabe's gonna have
a heart attack.
- Dude.
My Super Bowl pick:
the Texans.
- I love that we said it
on the pod yesterday.
- Holy crap.
- We brought them up, didn't we?
- What did they get for him?
A first and a second.
And Houston will also get a—
only a first and a second.
- All right. That's pretty good.
Well, they had to take
the salary into account.
- Man!
- Dude.
Damn. They might be
my new favorite team.
- Wow.
Do we change the whole show?
- Gosh damn.
What did we talk about
in the opening?
- I don't know.
- Hue.
You know what's crazy?
Is your first guess was right.
- Houston?
- No.
- My first guess of what?
- You know...
This ain't real, bro. You just
got pranked on Halloween.
- Are you f--king kidding me?
- [Gasping]
- You f--king ass----s.
Gabe. Did you know this, Gabe?
- Everybody knew, Chris!
Everybody knew!
- You d--k, Gabe!
- Everybody knew!
- You guys are such—
- How did you do this?!
- Everybody knew!
- Yesss!
I like how you
used ProFootballTalk
to make it real, too.
See, I know Lefkoe, though.
You see that?
He doesn't do this.
I know his tells.
"I have a full house!"
- Still fell for it, though.
Still fell for it, though.
- Damn. I really did.
- Yes!
- Gosh!
I'm gonna put all of you
in headlocks, one by one.
- All right, let's keep goin'.
- Oh my gosh.
- We asked you to send in pictures
of your beautiful children
for #NFLKids
dressed up like quarterbacks
or coaches or players.
Here's little Patrick Mahomes.
- What a cutie.
- Holy moly. That's awesome.
- Oh, Gronk!
- Gronk! Gronk!
- That's awesome.
- Let's keep this bad b—aww.
Oh my gosh.
- There he is, Chucky.
Got the same haircut as Chucky.
Wow. That kid is a special
human being right there.
Cute and really knows
his football.
I didn't know we could find
a Chris Simms jersey
that could fit a kid.
- That's very true.
- Damn.
- I am so happy that we got you.
- Damn. You really did.
- I could feel it.
- I can't believe it.
I was really just sittin' here
thinkin', like
"Man, the Houston Texans
with those three?
This is gonna be amazing."
Deshaun and Hopkins and Odell?
What?!
- You know what else is amazing?
Brady plays Rodgers.
- It is.
- "Sunday Night Football."
- Yes.
- Everyone knows that you would
take Rodgers over Brady——
- Yep.
- But they're both
in your top three.
- Yes.
- So don't send any hate mail!
What are we gonna see, man?
What is this gonna be like?
- Well, I think
we're gonna see, OK
the New England Patriots
try to take away
Aaron Rodgers' best target in
Davante Adams.
- As always.
- We know that. They're gonna try
to contain Rodgers in the pocket
cuz a lot of the great plays
he makes
are when he dances around and moves.
- Yes.
- So that's the thing.
Unfortunately, it's gonna be
Rodgers having to make magic
which is always my problem
with the Green Bay Packers.
- Story of his career.
- And then we're gonna see
New England on the other side.
- Dink, dink, dink, dink,
touchdown.
- Right, and Brady's gonna
execute and be on target
throwin' footballs
all over the field.
- Lotta basketball fans say one
of the greatest crying shames
is that Kobe and LeBron never
faced off in a championship.
- Right.
- I would say that Rodgers
and Brady never facing
in a Super Bowl is worse.
- Yes.
- Cuz Rodgers against Belichick
in the Super Bowl
with Brady on the other side?
- Well, if they caught
that onside kick—
- Against Seattle.
- In the lead-up to Seattle—
- And then
the Marshawn Lynch thing
never would've happened and the
interception by Malcolm Butler.
- Right. Who knows?
♪ Dun dun duh ♪
- Unbelievable.
That's it.
- That's it?
- Yeah.
- Good job, Ace.
- For Maverick.
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the A-C-E V-E-N-T-U-R-A.
- Man.
- We will holla atcha next week.
Enjoy the games.
♪♪♪
- [Gasping]
I can't do it, Goose, man.
I can't! I can't!
I can't get control of it!
- How do you think
Goose and Ace Ventura
would do in a cockpit together?
- Goose and—oh, gosh.
Well, we would crash.
- I feel like Ace would be like,
"I wonder what this button does!"